[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام
الامين العام للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
نور الدين الطبوبي الحكومه التونسيه
بالتحايل على الشعب منتقد الممارستها
وطريقه تعاطيها مع الملفات الاجتماعيه
تتوجه الى منظمه العمل الدوليه
لمقاضاه الحكومه
السيد محمد المسيليني عضو المكتب السياسيه
لحركه الشعب والوزير السابق سيد محمد اهلا
بكم ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه هذه
الدعوه
اهلا استاذ حكيم اهلين وسهلين مرحبا كل
الترحيب ومرحبا ايضا كل الترحيب مرحبا كل
الترحيب بك سيد المسيديني ورحب انا وانت
ايضا كل ترحيب بضيفي في الجانب المقابل من
تونس العاصمه دائما عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
السيد عصام الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري
سيد عصام الشامي اهلا بكم ومرحبا شكرا
جزيلا لك على تلبيه هذه الدعوه
ولكل المشاهدين
في تونس من الحكومه هل ذاق زرعا بها ونفذ
صبره منها فعلا كما يقولوا انصاره وما
تعليقكما على اتهامه لها اي للحكومه
بالتحيلي على الشعب عليك السؤال اولا سيد
عصام الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري مرحبا
من جديد
في الحقيقه يبدو ان
توصيفك صحيح عند الاتحاد اليوم
يعبر عن غضبه ونفاذ صبره من السياسه
الحكوميه سياسه ترفض التواصل مع الشركائه
في الوطن مع اهم المنظمات الاجتماعيه
والاحزب السياسيه يبدو ان تصريح الامين
العام للاتحاد عام تونسي للشغل يؤكد ان
سعه الحقيقه قد دقت بالنسبه لمنظومه السيد
قيس سعيد وحكومته نحن اليوم في تونس على
بعد ايام قليله من الانتخابات تدل كل
المؤشرات على انها ستدور بدون حضور
الجمهور وفي ظل همم اهتمام من المواطن
التونسي هي محاوله للرجوع الى الارسال
نظام فردي استبدالي يلغي التعدديه الحزبيه
والتفرقه بين الصلب ونحن ايضا تنضاف الى
ذلك اسم اقتصاديه واجتماعيه حقيقه لم يعد
ينفع معها للحلول للترقيعيه ولا تاجيل
الاستح النقطه الثانيه اليوم حكومه السيد
بدن ختمت همم منذ ايام قامت بتعديل قانون
الماليه للسنه الحاليه وهناك ثغره في
ميزانيه الدوله تقدر بتسعه مليار دينار
تونسي وليوجد اي تصور لي همم سداد هذا
المبلغ وهناك ايضا استعداد لنشر الميزانيه
العام القادم عن طريق مرسوم لان في تونس
ليس لا برلمان ولا مؤسسات تناقش قانون
الماليه وهذه الميزانيه القائد ما هي التي
تصير غضب وتخوفات المواطنين لانها
اعتبر هذه انها كانت التوته ولكن في ماذا
تحيلت الحكومه هل يستقيم مذهب اليه امين
عام اتحاد الشغل في تونس
يعني هذه الحكومه تعلن ورئيس الجمهوريه
اننا على التوجهات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
يعلن انحياز للفئات الشعبيه يعلن تمسكه
بالمكاسب الاجتماعيه للدوله التونسيه ورفض
للضغط على الاجراء وضعف الحال بينما في
واقع الامر السياسي الحكوميه تعمل على
مزيد همم الضغط على المواطن التونسي
واثقال كيف له
سياسي جيبائيه لم تعد تحتفل في هذه البلاد
وازام موجه من غلاء الاسعار دخلوا قبل
الدخول الى الاستوديو اطلعت على قرار من
وزاره النقل في تونس تعلن على زيادات مهمه
شرطه في تعريف طب نقل هذا النتيجه للسياسه
تنفع الدعم عن المحروقات والزياده في
المحروقات اتحاد الشغل في اعتقاده منذ
اشهر ما اتفاق لزياده في الاجور وكانت
مطالب الاتحاد معقوله وقبل بزياده منطقيه
وعلى امتداد ثلاث سنوات
اجتماعي سليم لكن التسريبات لانه اليوم
ليس هناك حوار في تونس التسريبات حول
ميزانيه الدوله للعام القادم تقول بان
الحكومه ستاخذ باليد اليسرى ما قدمته
للاجراء باليد اليمنى الاتحاد همم اخر ما
اثار عذابه منذ يوم منذ يومين توجه لب
دعوه من الحكومه للمشاركه
الحمار
في ضيف حقه في الجانب المقابل ولكن قبل
ذلك انوي لان ان صار اتحاد الشغل هم من
يقولون اليوم بان الاتحاد ذاق ذرعا
بالحكومه ونفذ صبره همم منها وهنا وعليه
سؤال سيد محمد المكتب السياسي في حركه
الشعب الوزير السابق هل تتفاهم انت غضب
اتحاد الشغل الذي تحدث صراحه بلهجه غير
مسبوق هل تحيلت فعلا الحكومه على شعبها في
مساله همم الدعم الاسعار
غريبه هل خدعتك فعلا كما يقول منتقدوه
الحكومه
اولا نشكرك على استضافه تحيه لك ولل ضيفك
الكريم صديقي
همم انا حقيقه همم الحديث على ان الحكومه
تحايلت على الشعب همم كلام غير سليم على
الاطلاق همم ولكن الواقعه الحقيقه الحكومه
تواجد صعوبات جديه واي حكومه كانت ستكون
في مكان هذه الحكومه ستواجه هذه الصعوبات
لان الوضع الاقتصادي كان من اصلا يعاني
صعوبات زادته الازمه العالميه من حولنا
وارتفاع اسعار المحروقات وارتفاع اسعار
المواد الى اخر هذا الموضوع المعلوم الان
عند كل كل الناس وهذا مثلا تشمل تقريبا كل
دول العالم ليس في خاص بتونس هذا زادته
تعقيدا لذلك اعتقد ان الحكومه همم وهي
تتجه الى صندوق النقد الدولي وهي امام
امام امور احلاها امور همم اقلها اقلها
ضررا يضر
لذلك هي تحاول ان تجد همم اخراجات همم
تعادل بين استحقاقات اللجوء الى الدائنين
الى المانحين وما يشترطونه من الشرطات
والحفاظ على الوضع الاجتماعي في البلاد
والحفاظ على القدره الشرعيه وهذه المساله
ليست سهله حتى في موضوع همم حتى في موضوع
الدعم الذي يتحدثون عن الحكومه سترفعه انا
وكيل لكان الحكومه واي حكومه لم تستطيع ان
ترفع الدعم مع المواد السياسيه سياتي على
موضوع المحروقات ولكن هي ستحاول تطبيق ما
يسمونه بتوجيه الدعم للمستحقيه وهو شعار
جميل لكن الحكومه الان لا تت- لا تملك
الماء الاليات ال- ال- الضروريه لتطبيق
هذا المبدا الجميل الذي حتى الاتحاد يا
خالد فيه انا اعتقد ان هذه اللهجه وهذا
الخطاب لا يؤدي الى شيء مزيد من تازيم
الاوضاع وهي عاده عشناها في تونس منذ
سنوات طويله خلال شهر ديسمبر وجامفي يكون
هناك تصعيد للوضع للسمان ضد هذا ايضا
الاتحاد لا يريد ان يعود بشكل قوي للساحه
السياسيه والنقابيه لانه شعوره وكانه همم
تقريبا خرج من المعادله في الفتره الاخيره
هذا يمكن ان نتفاهم ان يدافع عن منظوره
وهذا ما مقبول والاتحاد قوه التعديل في
السحب ولكن نحن الحقيقه ندعو الى ضروره ان
يكون هناك حوار جدي بين الحكومه والاتحاد
رغم ان هذه الحكومه عمرها قصير لان
المفروض تنتهي همم تنتهي بعد الانتخابات
بمده
ندعو الى حوار حقيقي لتوضيح هذه المساج
والابتعاد عن ترديد بعض الاشياء الغير
سليمه غير صحيحه طيب ما في شغل يقول انه
كان هناك لقاء همم
تبحث في قانون الماليه ولكن تم الاعتذار
عن هذا اللقاء او اليك ضيفي سيد عصام شادي
همم عاد كان كل شهر ديسمبر يقول لك
في تصعيد الوضع الاجتماعي من قبل الاتحاد
شغل واخرون همم يقولون فعلا انه امام
احتقان الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في
البلاد الحكومه ليست بهذه السذاجه حتى
تغامر بتفجير الوضع من خلال التلاعب
بمساله الدعم وهي احرس من يكون على السلم
الاجتماعي كيف يقول لك انا لا اكثر لا قلت
وجه بعض الصعوبات ككل البلدان في هذه
المرحله ولعلها فعلا لا تمتلك الاليات
لتوجيه الدعم لمستحقيه كيف ترد همم على
ذلك على ضوء ايضا مطالبه اتحاد الشغل
بالاطلاع على المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد
الدولي
انا اعتقد ان هذه الحكومه لم تعد تمتلك
قرارها في المجله الاقتصادي وهي اليوم
تتجه وتقبل بان تضع نفسها تحتوي صيد صندوق
النقد الدولي هذه الحكومه هي انهت وامضت
والتزمت بالتزامات ترفض ابتلاع التونسيين
على فحوها نحن اليوم في تونس لا نعلم انه
محتوى الاتفاق التقني الذي ابرمته الحكومه
التونسيه مع الصندوق الدولي والذي سيتم
المصادق عليه وابن المفروضه التي من
الصادقا عليه اواخر هذا الشهر وبالتالي
ادي الحكومه لم يقعد بامكانها الا اتباع
الشروط والاملايات التي فرضها صندوق النقد
الدولي وهي رفع الدعم عن المولد المحروقات
والحد من الانتداب في الوظيفه العموميه
والتفريط في المؤسسات العموميه وهذا ليست
جنديا للحكومه ولا على توجيهاتها بالورده
على لسان مدير الصندوق النقد الدول التي
صرحت وقالت ان حكومه السيد مدن قدمت وثيقه
فيها التزام بالتفريط في بعض المؤسسات
العموميه وهذا ما يتعارض مع كل الاعلانات
الرسميه لرئيس الجمهوريه والاضاءه الحكومه
بانهم لن يقبلوا بالتفريط في المكتسبات
الاجتماعيه وان هذه القضيه الاصلاحات
ستكون موضوعه حوار مع الشركاء الاجتماعيين
ما اثار غضب الاتحاد انه ذهب منذ يومين
الى دعوه الحكومه للتحاور حول
الحوكمه المؤسسات العموميه الا انه رغم
انه ارسل وفد رفيع المستوى فوزيه بغياب
رئيس الحكومه وجميع الوزاره وان العمليه
كان اخراج سيء لايهاب الداخل والخارج باذن
الحكومه تتفاوض مع الاتحاد والشركاء
الاجتماعيه هذا ما اثار حفيظه الاتحاد
وغضبه وخاصه ان كل التسريبات حول قانون
الماليه للعام القادم يقول بان هناك
التوجه لرفع الدعم عن المواد الاساسيه وان
وهدايه همم في تونس نتوقع انه سيثير همم
تاثير الس على الاستقرار الاهلي وعلى
السلم الاجتماعي وان الحكومه تدفع الدفعا
بخضع صندوق النقد الدولي ان تدخل البلاد
في شتاء ساخن لا يعلم الا الله نتائجها
خاصه وان تونس تمر همم بمواسطه ذلك باسم
السياسيه لا توجد قنوات للحوار لم اعرف
شركاء السياسي
وبالتالي هذه الحكومه اليوم الشعب التونسي
يعاني من موجه غير مسبوقه في غلاء الاسعار
ومن فقدان الاساسيه ومن اختلال
اليك همم
حركه الشعب الوزير السابق استمعت الى ضيف
يتحدث عن اخراج سيء للاها بالتفاوض واتحاد
الشغل يقول سينسيلين فعلا حتى عند الحديث
عن عن ماده السكر يقول لنا الدعم رفع بطرق
ملتويه واخرون في اتحاد الشغل قبل تحضير
هذه الحلقه همم قالوا لنا صراحه ان الحرص
على سلم الاجتماعي لا يمكن ان يكون
بمفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي يقصى منها
الشعب واتحاد الشغل وبالسعي ايضا الى همم
تمرين خيارات اقتصاديه يصفها الطبوب بنفسه
بالاستعماريه والسؤال الذي يطرح لماذا لم
يكن هناك حوار لماذا لم يكشف عن مضمون هذه
التفاهمات مع صندوق النقد اا الدوله
وتعاقب ايضا على ضيف لو سمحت
اولا نريد ان نوضح نقطه هامه جدا وهو انه
ا الوضع في تونس في حاجه لا يصلحات عميقه
بصندوق النقد الدولي وبدون صندوق النقد
الدولي مثلا حياه او موت بالنسبه لتونس
لانه لا يمكن ان تستمر الاوضاع اوضاع
الماليه العموميه اوضاع الاقتصاد اوضاع
الدم او ضاع
الموازنات وكان عايز الميزان
الميزانيه العامه للدوله الى اخر هذه
المؤشرات الكليه او التضخم الاخيره هذه
مثلا حياه وموت لا يمكن ان نستمر بهذا
الوضع لما ده طويل ثانيا الذهاب الى
المنيحين يفترض انه يقدم جمله من المعطيات
التي تسمح باصلاح الاوضاع فانا انا لا
حقيقه لا استسير كثيرا المصطلحها شروطه
صندوق النقد صندوق الصندوق النقد الدولي
التجاربهم على الشعوب معروفه احنا نقبل او
لا نقبل هذا هو الموضوع الموضوع عندنا مش
عند صندوق النقد الدولي لذلك اعتقد انه
حتى الذهاب الى الصندوق النقد الدولي الان
هو شر لابد منها لا يوت لا توجد حكومه
الان مهما كانت توجهها السياسي لا لا تذهب
الى الاقتراض الان من اجل مواجهه الوضع
الاقتصادي والمالي في البلاد لماذا لا يتم
الذهاب في كان في التحاور عفوا على
المقاطعه طيب سياتي لهذا
الموضوع
كيف ذهب اليسار الى حلول حتى اليمين رفض
انه يطبقها انت تعرف هذا جيد انا اعتقد ان
هناك نقيسه عن هذه الحكومه او لن هذه
الوثيقه ما زالت غير رسميه لانه عندما
تصبح رسميا ينشره حتى صندوق النقد الدولي
ثانيا اعتقد انه من زمان نحن نعرف ما هي
النقاط الاساسيه التي يجب التركيز عليها
هي موضوع الذهب موضوع نظيف العموميه او
اصلاح الاداره بشكل عام موضوع اصلاح
المؤسسات العموميه وموضوع اصلاح صرف
وتنشيط الاقتصاد هذه العناوين الكبرى التي
عارف والقاسي وداني في كل مفاوضات وفي كل
مرحله همم الحكومه لا تخرج هذا الاطار
وانا اؤكد لك مره اخرى هذه الحكومه وغيرها
غير قادر على رفع الدعم اطلاقا الا اذا
كانت تريد ان تدخل البلاد في في مازق كبير
جدا لذلك خلينا نتحدث بشكل عقلاني ومعقول
لا هي قادره بتبيع مؤسسات والاقي قادر بس
ترفع الدعم عن المواد الاساسيه الا اذا
كانت تريد ان تدخل البلاد في في هذا يعتقد
ان هذا التوجه الموجود لا للحكومه ولا
رئيس الجمهوريه اعتقد انه هناك حاله من
ال- ال- محاوله رفع الخطاب السياسي
والخطاب المتشنج في البلاد من هذا الطرف
وهذاك يزيد من تشنج الاوض
المفيد للبلاد الان المفروض طبعا هناك
لقيصه انا اقول لك ان الحكومه همم
تتعاطى مع المواطنين مع الاعلام مع مع همم
زينب التواصل مع الاتحاد شغل معايا
المنظمات هناك نقيس كبرى في غياب هذا
الحوار المجتمعي في غياب هذا الحوار
بالتاكيد ونحن ندعو الى حوار حقيقي بين كل
الاطراف اللي خاصه للاجتماعيه سيدي خلينا
من السياسيين اعطينا الاجتماعيه لطرف
الاجتماعيه اتحاد الشغل اتحاد صناعه
والتجاره اتحاد الفلاحين الى اخر هذا هذا
هذه ناس تفعل في السوق اما الذهاب الى ال-
ال- ال- اما الذهاب الى منظمه العمل
الدوليه وغير واعتقد ان هذا مجرد ترفع في
الخطاب الاتحاد يلتزم بالضوابط الوطنيه
ويدرك جيدا
تصعيد خطابي الى اكثر ولا اقل طبعا
يعني يندرج حسابات داخليه الله اعلم ما هي
الاتحاد ولكن الاتحاد
تهديده والاعلان عن الذهب لمنظمه العمل
الدوليه تصيد خطابي ولا اقل والت- الاتحاد
سيلتزم يقول ضيفي قطعه الاتصال معك الى
السيدري ان كنت استمعت اليه سيد عصام
الشلبي ويقول لك الذهاب الى صندوق النقد
الدولي شرا لا بد منه الحكومه غير قادر
على رفع الدعم غير قادره على بيع والتفريط
في المؤسسات ويضيف النتيجه الاتفاق مع
صندوق النقد الدولي ما زال في مرحله اوليه
على مستوى الخبراء ولم يحدث اتفاق وما
تحدث هذا الاتفاق سيتم الكشف عنه ويقر
بنقيصه غياب همم الحوار المجتمعي همم هذه
يقرب بها تفضل
سيدي نحن اليوم منظومه لا تؤمن بالحوار
السيد قيس سيد وحكومته لا يؤمنون بالحوار
لا مع الاطراف السياسيه مع الاطراف
الاجتماعيه السيد قيس عيد الغا دستور
الجمهوريه التونسيه ورسم دستور جديد
بمفرده فرضه على التونسي يذهب الى
الانتخابات على مقاسه كلف حكومه مسؤول
امامه ولا تتواصل مع تونسين والترفض طلعت
لسين على حقيقه التزاماتها الدوليه في
المجال الاقتصادي هذه الحكومه والصياد
سعيد على راسها لا يملكون التصورا ولا
سياسه لاصلاح او وضعنا للاقتصاديه
المتنديه اذا كانت هذه الحكومه لها رؤيه
اقتصادي ما الذي منعها منذ اكثر من عام
وهي تمسك بالحكم بصوره منفرده ان تبادل
الى مباشره هذه الاصلاحات كل ما في الامر
انها هذه الحكومه بصدد اعداد ملف للحصول
على قروض وهذه القروض تستوجب منها ان تذهب
الى الشر الشارع له السيد محمد المسليني
الحكومه ترفض اطلاع التونسيين على محتوى
الوثيقه التي امضتها مع صندوق النقد
الدولي لانها تعلم علم اليقين بان ذلك
سيثير غضبا التونسيين وسيننهي ما يسمى
بشعبيه هذه المنظومه التي تحكم البلاد
بصوره في رديه منذ عام ونصف تقريبا واتحاد
الشغل اليوم عند ما يهدد بالذهاب الى
منظمه العمل الدوليه هو لا يتخلى لا عن
وطنيته ولا عن حدوده سبقا للاتحاد في ظروف
السابقون في حكومه السابقه في عهد الرئيس
بلقب ان ذهب الى منظمه العمل الدوليه
واشتكى الحكم في تونس لانتيكا الانتهاكي
للانتفاقات
النقبيه في تونس ولي حقوق العمل
وللمكتسبات الاجتماعيه في بلادنا
الاتفاقات التي امرتنا الحكومه اليوم
اتحاد الشغل يطالب هذه الحكومه بان تفعل
الاتفاقات التي امضتها معه منذ قرابه
العام هذه الحكومه تمضي على الاتفاقات
تدخل في فوضت الاتحاد يقبل بالتنازلات من
اجل الحفاظ على الاستقرار البلاد ولكن
يوجد نفسه امام حكومه تتنكر حتى
الانذائاتها وترفض تنظيم تلك الاتفاقات
هذا هو ما يدفع البلاد اليوم نحو بمزيد من
التوتر وهذه الحكومه تتحمل مسئوليه دفع
البلاد دفعا نحو التصدع ونحو الانفجار
اليوم بالاوضاع في بلادنا الاتحاد ايضا
غاضب منتدهور الاوضاع السياسيه وتدور
اوضاع الحريات الحقوق والحريات العامه
والفرديه وقال لها ان العام الاتحاد بان
هذه المنظمه عتيده لا تقفوا على الحياه في
قضيه الحقوق الحريات وانها تنتصر الى حريه
الى حريه التعبير وحق التنقل وحق التظاهر
لان هذه الحريات اليوم تضيق والمحاكمه
تتزايد في بلادنا
ويتكهرب اكثر يوما بعد ايه الجميع يرى بان
تونس تتجه الى احترام الاهلي نرفض ان نبقى
في موقع المتفرج اليه النداب والعقل
تدعي ان ندخل في حوار وطني شامل بين
الاطراف السياسيه والاجتماعيه وقاده الراي
في بلادنا
لاستنباسيه وان تكون واحده فقط
في تصريحات همم سيد نور الدين الطبيب
الطبيب يقول للبلاد ماشيه في سكه غالطه
غالطه فمتى على ما يبدوبه امل كما تخيشها
من معركه اجتماعيه يقول اتحاد الشغل انه
مستعد همم لها تعليقك على ضيفي في دقيقه
لو سمحت همم معك
اولا لا اريد ان اطمئن التونسيين
والتونسيات وكل الاصدقاء من حولنا لن نكون
هناك حرام داخلي على الاطلاق الامور لحد
الان في حاله صحيح هناك غلاوه هناك رفض
وهناك كذا هناك وهناك
حاله من الغضب على الاوضاع اللي هي ولكن
لن يكون هناك حرام على الاطلاق الدوله
مستقره وستمر مستقره بغض النظر يحكم انا
اعتقد انه خطاب ايضا سن نور الدين الطبوبي
انا قلت بصفات الشغل ومنظمه موجوده من اجل
التوازن في البلاد هذا الاستك فيه ولكن
اعتقد انه همم همم سيكون هناك لقاءات في
المستقبل القريب مع الحكومه ويمكن حتى ما
راي الجمهوريه من اجل النظر في هذا
الموضوع وستهدا الامور بالنسبه للاتحاد
انا اتاكد ان الامور ستسير نحو ستسير نحو
التهدئه وليست نحو ولا التصعيد بالنسبه
للاتحاد العام في الشغل الذي يحرز دائما
على نحافظ على التوزنات الموجوده في
البلاد وانا همم انا اقول لكل الاصدقاء من
المعارضه ومن السياسيين ابتعدوا عن توظيف
في وضع الاتحاد في خلافاتكم السياسيه مع
الحكومه لان لن تفيد الاتحاد لن يصطف وراء
اي حزب ولا اي اي مشكله سيبقى دائما بعيدا
هذه الاستفاده كل شكرا جزيلا لكم يا سيدنا
الشعب والوزير السابق على تربيه دعوتنا
هذا المساء وكل الشكر جزيلا لك ايضا سيد
عصام الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري كنتما
معنا في فقره وجهها